but we begin this half-hour with the
first step in president Trump's plan to
build a border wall with Mexico Border
Patrol agents will begin testing eight
wall prototypes to see how easy they are
to climb over or dig under but as Millea
via dialler explains there's no
guarantee that any will be chosen or
that a wall will even be built we will
begin working on an impenetrable
beautiful southern border wall beauty
may be in the eye of the beholder or in
this case border patrol which now has
eight completed prototypes of what
president Trump's border wall could look
like four of the designs are solid
concrete the rest use steel and other
materials and in 2018 Border Patrol is
asking for a 1.6 billion dollar
downpayment most of which would go to
begin building the wall it's a fraction
of the overall estimated price tag of 21
billion dollars in a report released
earlier this year the inspector
general's office was skeptical that
building a wall would make an impact
saying the southwest border is still
porous and questions remain as to
whether CBP's significant investments
have resulted in better security Pedro
Rios is a director of the American
Friends Services Committee I think what
the president is saying is essentially
trying to use this as a cover to pretend
that he is responding to a promise that
he made to his constituency Juana
Rodriguez has watched the construction
from her home in Tijuana Mexico Green
que la gente para encontrar una manera
para cortar
once you stated pending to negotiation
estados unidos she says if there's work
in the united states people will always
find a way to cross polls also show only
32 percent of Americans support the wall
49 percent oppose it including 41
percent who are strongly against it but
Border Patrol's acting deputy
commissioner Ronald Vitello says the
need is evident mortar walls have proven
to be an extremely effective part of our
multi-pronged security strategy to
prevent the illegal migration of people
and drugs once you choose the best of
these prototypes
is there a guarantee that the wall will
be built there are a lot of things that
have to happen to make this work so no I
think the limiting factor is the
Appropriations for it once the testing
process is over Border Patrol will pick
parts of each prototype they like best
but there probably won't be one singular
winner on top of that the contractors
had made these prototypes aren't
guaranteed to make the final version of
the wall they'll have to go through
another bidding process so far there is
no timeline on that for CBS this morning
Saturday midday ovule along the San
Diego Tijuana border I've been to the
border wall in Nogales and it is a
massive massive massive construction to
think of the undertaking required to
extend something that big that far that
far I mean it is a Multi multi year
process